Willkommen an der Teresianischen Militärakademie.
Ich bin Carl Marcus Reisner. Ich bin Leiter
der Forschungs- und Entwicklungsabteilung
der Akademie und derzeit
Kommandeur der Wacheinheit in Wien.
Heute in unserem Briefing werfen wir einen Blick
auf die  Krieg um die Ukraine, und wir werfen einen
Blick auf die ersten daraus gezogenen Lehren und
die nächsten Herausforderungen, die wir
in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten erwarten oder sehen könnten.
Es sind 324 Tage und es handelt sich um eine
Aktualisierung des Konflikts.
Es ist wichtig, das alles zu verstehen  Meine
Einschätzung liegt in einem
Koordinatensystem, das durch
verschiedene Domänen definiert ist. Wir haben also die
Weltraumdomäne, die Luftdomäne, die
Seedomäne, die Landdomäne und natürlich die
Cyber- und die Informationsdomäne.
Sie können also sehen, dass alle
unterschiedlich sind  In diesen Bereichen passieren Dinge
und all diese interagieren
miteinander.
Daher müssen wir zunächst
zwischen der taktischen, der operativen und
der strategischen Ebene unterscheiden. Die technische Ebene
bedeutet bestimmte Waffensysteme wie die
Heimer-Systeme und welche Art von
Fähigkeiten sie haben. Die operative Ebene
bedeutet Offensiven  Das heißt, die
Offensive in Kiew
und die Ebene, auf der die Angriffe stattfinden, sind die Ebene, die
ausschlaggebend ist, wenn es um die
Frage geht, wie lange man tatsächlich einen Krieg führen kann,
also in diesem bestimmten Fall zum Beispiel
die Angriffe von russischer Seite auf die
kritische Infrastruktur der Ukraine,
also lasst uns  Beginnen wir mit der taktischen Ebene:
Wir wissen, dass die Russen 2014
mit dem System
der taktischen Bataillonsgruppe in die Ukraine einmarschierten. Sie taten
dasselbe im Februar 2022, aber das
Problem bestand darin, dass
diese Struktur nicht ausreichte, um
tiefer in die Ukraine vorzudringen
Das größte Problem des Landes war der Mangel
an Infanterie. Auf der anderen Seite
verwendeten die Ukrainer sehr ausgefeilte
Techniken und Taktiken und
verwendeten auch moderne Waffensysteme wie
Drohnen oder bestimmte Arten von
Artilleriemunition, was
der russischen Seite hohe Verluste zufügte. Daher ist es wichtig, dies zu tun
Wir verstehen, dass die Taktik, Techniken
und Verfahren entscheidend sind, wenn es
um die taktische Ebene geht.
Die nächste Ebene ist die operative Ebene.
Hier können wir sehen, dass
die Ukrainer zur Überraschung vieler Experten in der
Lage waren, der russischen Seite hohe Verluste zuzufügen
Mehr oder weniger drei
erfolgreiche Operationen, nämlich die
Operation in der Gegend von Kiew-
Harkiw und Kershaw. Auf der anderen Seite
war die russische Seite nicht in der Lage,
alle Fußstapfen zu gewinnen, die sie zu
Beginn des Konflikts erobern wollte, aber
sie konnten auch kämpfen  gegen die
ukrainische Seite in entscheidender Weise, wie wir es
in meiner echten Umfrage Severo
Tonshansk gesehen haben, und natürlich hat das in dem Moment
unsere Schlagstimmung
so verändert, dass es eine Weile gedauert hat, sich anzupassen,
aber die russische Seite war in der Lage, sich
im weiteren Kampf anzupassen  Auf der operativen Ebene
ist Flexibilität etwas, das
auf dieser Ebene sehr wichtig ist.
Die strategische Ebene ist wichtig, wenn es um
die Frage geht, wie
lange man den Krieg führen kann, und wie Sie
sehen können, ist
die Tatsache, dass die Russen herausgefunden haben,
dass sie es getan haben  Probleme auf der
operativen Ebene, aber durch den Einsatz ihrer
strategischen Mittel
wie Langstreckenbomber oder sogar Drohnen
und Marschflugkörper konnten sie
der kritischen Infrastruktur der Ukraine großen Schaden zufügen,
was bedeutet, dass
die Russen anfangs
mit ihren Angriffen recht erfolgreich waren, aber die  Die
erfolgreichsten Angriffe begannen natürlich
am 10. Oktober, als
sie begannen, die kritische
Infrastruktur der ukrainischen Seite anzugreifen, und
bis heute hat die ukrainische Seite immer noch
Probleme damit, ihre
Luftverteidigungsanlagen zur Verteidigung der kritischen
Infrastrukturstandorte einzusetzen, sodass die Ausdauer
oft in Konflikt gerät  Das ist sehr wichtig, wir
haben derzeit etwa 11 Monate Zeit.
Lassen Sie uns nun über die wichtigsten
Fähigkeiten zur Kriegsführung sprechen. Es gibt
mehrere davon, und wie Sie sehen,
interagieren alle diese Fähigkeiten miteinander
und es ist wichtig,
in jedem von ihnen über Ressourcen und Fähigkeiten zu verfügen
Felder, die es ermöglichen,
einen Feind erfolgreich anzugreifen. Fangen wir
mit dem ersten an, und das ist die Vorbereitung.
Wie wir zu Beginn des Konflikts gesehen haben,
waren die Ukrainer gut vorbereitet, als
es um den russischen Angriff ging. Ein gutes
Beispiel ist der Kampf um den  Kiew, wo die
Ukrainer durch die Überschwemmung des Flussufers
und die Zerstörung der Brücken
den russischen Vormarsch stoppen konnten und durch den Einsatz von
Artilleriesystemen
der russischen Seite hohe Verluste zufügen konnten und auch durch
den Einsatz kleiner Einheiten der Spezialeinheiten
Treffer erzielt wurden  Die Russen
verteilten den Konvoi über weite
Strecken und konnten
der russischen Seite hohe Verluste zufügen. Daher
ist die richtige Planung entscheidend, wenn es
um die Kriegsführung geht.
Das nächste wichtige Projekt ist ein Projekt. Projekt
bedeutet also, wie es möglich ist  Sorgen Sie für einen
stetigen Zufluss von Kräften und Ressourcen für
Ihre Kampftruppe, und wir haben gesehen,
dass auch die russische Seite in der Lage ist,
sich anzupassen, da
sie beispielsweise in der Lage war, die russischen
Truppen mit 50 bis 60.000 Soldaten über 1000 Kilometer aus dem Gebiet von Kiew abzuziehen
Mit dem
Zug zum Donbass, wo sie begannen,
in der zweiten Phase des Konflikts eine neue Hauptanstrengung zu entwickeln.
Auf der
anderen Seite
konnten die Ukrainer alle
eingehenden Ressourcen aller
Waffensysteme von Polen in die Ukraine und zu
ihren Streitkräften kanalisieren  Sie wurden tatsächlich im
Kampf gegen
die Russen eingesetzt,
daher ist der Schwung sehr wichtig. Man
muss immer einen gleichmäßigen Schwung haben,
wenn es ums Kämpfen geht,
also ist die nächste Fähigkeit „Eingreifen“, „Eingreifen“, „Eingreifen“, „Bedeuten“ im
Krieg, „Kampfeinsätze“ auch „
Angreifen“ und „die Fähigkeit,
es anzugreifen“.  Es ist interessant zu sehen, dass sich der Konflikt nach der
dritten Woche in den ersten Wochen
sehr schnell auf eine Weise entwickelte,
die von vielen Experten nicht erwartet worden war,
und zwar durch den Einsatz massiver
Artilleriesysteme auf beiden Seiten, und wie
Sie hier sehen können, ist es so  Es ist wichtig zu
verstehen, dass beim
Angriff auf andere mit Artilleriesystemen
der Faktor Geschwindigkeit
entscheidend ist und wir auf
ukrainischer Seite eine hohe Flexibilität und eine
Befehls- und Kontrollstruktur gesehen haben, die
es ermöglicht hat,
sofort nach der
Erkennung eines Angriffs zuzuschlagen  Zielverluste auf der
russischen Seite, während auf der anderen Seite die
Russen über ein sehr zentralisiertes Anforderungssystem verfügten,
dauerte es fast eine Weile, bis die angeforderten
Artilleriesysteme tatsächlich
auf die Ukraine im Inneren einwirkten. Daher ist es wichtig
zu verstehen, dass die Geschwindigkeit ein entscheidender
Faktor ist, wenn es darum geht  Um
die nächste Fähigkeit zu bekämpfen, ist es am
Ende der zweiten Phase der Beschwörung
so, dass nicht klar war, ob
die Russen
aufgrund des Einsatzes
ihrer massiven Artilleriesysteme und
der Lieferung der amerikanischen Heimat über die Ukraine Insight siegen werden
Durch den Einsatz dieser Raketen war es möglich,
die russischen Amity-
Pole anzugreifen, und es dauerte eine Weile, bis die
Russen
die Amity-Pole zerstreuten. Um
sie zu schützen, nutzten sie das Pantry-
System, um ihre Amity-Pole
gegen die ankommenden Raketen zu verteidigen. Dies war
erfolgreich  Also mussten die Amerikaner ein
anderes Waffensystem einführen und das
war die Anti-Radar-Rakete Hem-88. Diese
Raketen zerstörten das Durchschlagssystem
und natürlich war es
den Hymer-Systemen wieder möglich, Ziele
auf der russischen Seite anzugreifen,
so dass präzise Waffen sehr wichtig sind  Wichtig im
Konflikt und natürlich aufgrund
der Tatsache, dass diese Waffen
gegen neue Ressourcen wirken können und man über
Ressourcen verfügen muss, wenn man
einen Konflikt über einen längeren Zeitraum bekämpfen möchte.
Die nächste Fähigkeit ist die Nachhaltigkeit. Wir werden uns
bei der Betrachtung mit der Nachhaltigkeit befassen  bei den
Streitkräften und natürlich bei der Munition, sodass wir
wissen, dass beide Seiten zu Beginn
des Konflikts über bestimmte Fähigkeiten verfügten,
nämlich die der Invasionstruppen und die der
verteidigenden Streitkräfte. Die verteidigenden Streitkräfte
konnten über zwei Monate hinweg
erfolgreich gegen die Invasionstruppen kämpfen  Auf
russischer Seite verlor die Ukraine laut ukrainischen Quellen bis zum Sommer
etwa 50 Prozent ihrer
Ausrüstung.
Daher war es wichtig, dass neue Ausrüstung
eintraf und der Westen
etwa 1400 Panzer, Infanterie-
Kampffahrzeuge und Artilleriesysteme lieferte, und diese
Ausrüstung ermöglichte es der Ukraine, dies
zu tun  Die neue Offensive innerhalb von
Cason und Hakif wurde erneut gestartet, was bedeutete, dass die
Ukraine
viel Ausrüstung erhielt, die es ihr
ermöglichte, weiter anzugreifen. Auf
der anderen Seite hatten die Russen ebenfalls
hohe Verluste, aber auch hier waren sie
immer in der Lage und in der Lage, einzuspringen  Sie schließen ihre
Lücken, indem sie neue Ressourcen aus
Russland einbringen, und wenn wir uns natürlich auch
die Munition ansehen, können wir sehen,
dass die Ressourcen, über die die russische Seite
verfügt, offensichtlich deutlich größer sind als die der
Ukraine. Man sagt, dass die
Russen etwa 17 Millionen
Artilleriegeschosse (sieben) haben  Millionen von ihnen haben sie
während der Kämpfe in den letzten Monaten eingesetzt.
Sie können ungefähr 3,4 Millionen pro
Jahr produzieren, was bedeutet, dass genug
für den Kampf gegen die Ukraine in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten verfügbar ist.
Lassen Sie uns jetzt über „Informieren“ sprechen  Es ist
wichtig zu verstehen, dass
die
USA und auch die NATO unmittelbar nach Beginn des Konflikts damit begannen,
Ukraine Insight durch die Bereitstellung von
Geheimdienstinformationen zu unterstützen. Diese Geheimdienstinformationen
ermöglichten es, die
Kommando- und Kontrollpositionen der
russischen Seite anzugreifen und der Ukraine hohe Verluste zuzufügen
Russische Generäle bedeuteten, dass es den
Russen nicht nur an Infanterie mangelte,
sondern sie hatten auch hohe Verluste, was sich
natürlich auf ihre Kriegsführung auswirkte.
Auf der anderen Seite konnten die
Ukrainer durch den Einsatz mehrerer tausend
Drohnen ein sehr gutes
Lagebild haben, was aber nicht der Fall war
Diese Drohnen wurden nur dazu verwendet,
bestimmte Vermögenswerte der russischen
Seite ins Visier zu nehmen, sie wurden aber auch bewaffnet eingesetzt, um
Munition abzuwerfen und natürlich,
um der russischen Seite Schaden zuzufügen.
Daraus können wir schließen, dass der
Begriff „Geheimdienst“ tatsächlich der wichtigste ist
von all den verschiedenen Fähigkeiten,
denn es ist entscheidend zu verstehen,
wo sich der Feind befindet und wo wir
unsere Ressourcen einsetzen müssen, um den Feind anzugreifen und zu treffen.
Lassen Sie uns jetzt darüber sprechen, Befehl
und Kontrolle zu konsultieren,
damit wir sehen können, dass es zwei Dinge gibt,
die es gibt  Wichtig hierbei
ist erstens die Art und Weise, Truppen zu führen und zu führen,
und zweitens natürlich die
Kommunikation. Wir wissen, dass die
Ukrainer durch die Verwendung von Starlink
bis heute in der Lage waren, sehr
schnell und erfolgreich zu kommunizieren, und wir kennen auch
diese Art und Weise  Die Ukrainer haben
in den letzten Jahren trainiert und die Ausbildung der
Soldaten war sehr erfolgreich, weil
sie verstanden haben, dass das Missionskommando
ein sehr, sehr wichtiger Führungsvorteil ist.
Auf der anderen Seite arbeitet die russische Führung
sehr zentralisiert, so dass es
immer eine Weile dauert, bis die Lage
und das Bewusstsein verloren gehen  Der Boden
erreicht tatsächlich die höhere Ebene, aber wenn die
höhere Ebene eine klare Vorstellung davon hat, was sie
versteht, können sie
ihre Truppen natürlich so führen, dass es
erfolgreich ist. Wir haben das gesehen, als wir uns
die Situation bei Carson angesehen haben, die
ein wenig so aussieht  Dünkirchen im Jahr 1914,
wo die Russen
30.000 Soldaten und zweieinhalbtausend
Redner auf der anderen Seite abziehen konnten,
ohne von der ukrainischen Seite angegriffen zu werden.
Sie fragen sich vielleicht, woher
diese Einschätzungen kommen. Ist
dies eine Einschätzung unserer Abteilung?  Oder
stammt es aus anderen Quellen, und natürlich
aus anderen Quellen, die ich jetzt
tatsächlich verwendet habe, um Ihnen die Kurzfassung zu geben, also
gibt es zwei bestimmte
Papiere, auf die ich wirklich
hinweisen möchte. Beide Papiere, die für
die Präsentationen verwendet werden, stammen von der Royal  Die
Wand des United Service Institute for Defense and Security Studies befasst sich tatsächlich mit den
aus den
ersten Monaten des Konflikts gezogenen Lehren und Erkenntnissen, wenn es
um die russische Invasion geht, und die
andere Wand befasst sich zusätzlich mit der Leistung
der russischen Luftwaffe
Verwendete Zitate der ukrainischen Chefin des
Channel-Stabs Valerie Solution und
des US-Vorsitzenden der China Chiefs
Mark Miley und natürlich
des estnischen Chefs des
Militärgeheimdienstes, also sagte er, wenn Sie
möchten, dass die Ukraine wiederkommen kann
Um eine neue Offensive zu starten,
brauche ich weitere 300 Panzer, 600 bis 700
Infanterie-Kampffahrzeuge und 500
Artilleriegeschütze,
und Mark Miley sagte nach Kerson, dass
beide Seiten 100.000 Tote
und Verwundete im Kampf verloren haben, und er war
der Erste, der das sagte, und er  Gesagt wurde auch
eine Möglichkeit, miteinander zu reden
und Grossberg Carl Grossberg sagte, dass die
russischen Fähigkeiten immer noch hoch sind und es
noch viel gibt, was sie im Konflikt nutzen können. Um
die
Aussagen zusammenzufassen, möchte ich das
folgende Zitat von einem der verwenden  UC
dokumentiert, dass
die Auffassung besteht, dass die
Streitkräfte der Russischen Föderationen
systematisch inkompetent und
unwiederbringlich korrumpiert sind, dass ihre Waffen
unwirksam und unzuverlässig sind und dass
die Streitkräfte nicht in der Lage sind, sich anzupassen. Dieses
Narrativ ist gefährlich,
weil es ungenau ist und auch,
weil es Selbstgefälligkeit fördert
Was ich hier betonen möchte,
ist nicht hilfreich zu sagen, dass die Russen
nicht in der Lage sind, einen Krieg zu führen, weil wir
verstehen müssen, dass die Ukraine
weitere
Hilfe im Kampf gegen die russische
Seite benötigt, wenn sie den Krieg gewinnen will. Das
würde ich gerne tun  Ich gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel, denn
Sie alle wissen, dass
der britische Geheimdienst
uns täglich über Neuigkeiten informiert, und ich
möchte Ihnen zwei Beispiele nennen, die
Ihnen eine Vorstellung davon vermitteln,
wo das Problem zwischen
Wunsch und Realität liegt. Ab Juni
haben wir also hier einen, der das sagt
Die Angriffe der russischen Seite haben keinen
nennenswerten Einfluss auf den Konflikt und da
die russischen Bestände an präzisen
Lenkflugkörpern
im Dezember erheblich aufgebraucht waren,
sieht es völlig anders aus,
denn hier können wir sehen,
dass die Russen das Energieverteilungsnetz ins Visier nehmen,
und das können sie auch  Die
ukrainische Luftverteidigung zu überwältigen oder zumindest zu versuchen,
und dies hat zur Folge, dass sie versuchen,
die Moral der ukrainischen
Bevölkerung zu untergraben und natürlich die kritische Infrastruktur zu zerstören,
und wie Präsident Selenski erst kürzlich
im November sagte, waren es bereits
über 4.700 Raketen  Sie werden gegen die
kritische Infrastruktur in der Ukraine und gegen
Ziele in der Ukraine eingesetzt, und die Zahl
liegt derzeit bei über 5000.
Während wir über die
Fähigkeiten der russischen Seite diskutieren,
versucht das russische Militär, uns zu beeinflussen,
indem es den Informationsbereich dominiert,
und was sie tun, ist Folgendes  Durch die Nutzung vieler
verschiedener Medien und natürlich der
sozialen Medien versuchen sie, zu einem
Nebel des Krieges beizutragen, der es sehr schwierig macht,
die aktuelle Situation, den
Konflikt und
die Frage am Ende zu verstehen, was
in Ordnung ist, was noch benötigt wird
Besonders für die ukrainische Seite und
wo stehen wir im Konflikt? Es ist
interessant, dass wir bestimmte
Fragen aufwerfen und versuchen können, diese
Fragen selbst zu beantworten. Dann wissen Sie,
wo wir im Konflikt stehen. Das
erste, was wir uns also fragen müssen, ist,
warum  Ist es so, dass die amerikanische
Seite
in den nächsten Monaten und Jahren nur 20 Hymer-Systeme und vielleicht weitere 18 geliefert hat
und nicht 50 und
100, wie der Ukrainer sagte?
Warum hat die amerikanische Seite keine
Kampfflugzeuge wie F-16 oder sogar A. geliefert?  -10 Warthog
und richtig, sie haben keine auf
Konten abgeliefert, was bedeutet, dass Raketen mit
größerer Distanz und Reichweite auf der anderen
Seite bereits eine Patriot-
Batterie abgeliefert haben und auch die Deutschen werden
eine abliefern, aber zwei Patriot-Batterien
reichen zur Verteidigung nicht aus  den Luftraum
der Ukraine im Inneren gegen diese
strategischen Angriffe der Russen zu schützen, und
eine Sache, die heftig diskutiert wird, ist
die Lieferung schwerer Waffen wie Panzer
und Infanterie-Kampffahrzeuge, und
natürlich werden die Amerikaner, wie wir
aus den Erklärungen der letzten Tage wissen,
50 davon liefern  Bradleys und
die Deutschen haben 40 Martyr-Infanterie-
Kampffahrzeuge und natürlich haben die Briten
bereits gesagt, dass sie 10 Herausforderungen liefern werden,
und vielleicht werden auch die Polen und die Finnen
weitere 20
Leoparden-Sachen liefern,
aber jetzt vergleichen wir noch einmal, was als
allgemeine Lösung gesagt wurde und was  Er
sagte: „Ich
brauche 300 Panzer, 6 bis 700 Infanterie-
Kampffahrzeuge und 500
Artilleriesysteme, und jetzt haben wir hier 30 Panzer
und etwa 90 Infanterie-Kampffahrzeuge“,
also können wir hier sehen, dass es einen Unterschied
zwischen ihnen gibt  Angesichts dieser Zahlen
ist es wichtig zu verstehen, dass die
Russen versuchen, mehr und mehr
Kräfte einzusetzen. Sie versuchen,
die Reservekräfte so zusammenzubringen,
dass sie sie tatsächlich an
der gesamten Front einsetzen können, insbesondere in der
Verteidigungsstellung  Wir sehen also, dass immer mehr
Russen auf die
andere Seite drängen. Wir sehen immer noch, dass es
Lücken gibt, wenn man die Anzahl der
Panzer, gepanzerten Fahrzeuge und sogar der
Artilleriesysteme vergleicht, und dass Russland immer noch
versucht, so viel wie möglich ins Land zu bringen
Das heißt, es ist klar, dass die Ukraine
mehr Ausrüstung benötigt, um diesen
russischen Angriffen auf taktischer Ebene entgegenzuwirken. Auf
der operativen Ebene
ist es wichtig zu verstehen, dass
die gesamte eingehende Ausrüstung
von den Ukrainern verwendet wird, um zwei Kernelemente zu bilden
Einer im Bereich von
Polterva und der andere in den Bereichen
von drei Vorfeld-Annäherungen. Der eine Kern
ist nach der Bereitstellung derjenige, der
Richtungen angreifen
und möglicherweise die Versorgungsleitungen abschneiden könnte, die
von Russland nach Tombas kommen,
das andere Kernelement könnte angreifen  Aus dem
Saporoshi-Gebiet Richtung Miliz Mall im
Zusammenhang mit einem Angriff auf die
strategisch wichtige Brücke über die
Couch-Straße
wären diese Operationen die
erfolgreicheren, da sie
nicht nur hohe Verluste auf der
russischen Seite verursachen würden, sondern auch die
russischen Truppen auf der Krim saporosisch isolieren würden
Natürlich Castle,
was kann man auf der strategischen
Ebene erwarten? Auf der einen Seite versuchten die Ukrainer,
die kritische
Infrastruktur mit den notwendigen Mitteln der
Luftverteidigung zu verteidigen, auf der anderen Seite
versuchten die Ukrainer aber auch,
die Räume anzugreifen, in denen sich die strategischen Bomber befanden
oder sogar  Die Schiffe sind stationiert,
die Träger von Marschflugkörpern sind,
die in der Ukraine hohe Verluste verursachen,
und was hier zu erwarten ist, ist,
dass wir weitere Angriffe auf die
Ukraine im Inneren, auch tief im Land
in Russland,
mit dem Ziel sehen werden, diese tatsächlich zu treffen
strategische Vermögenswerte von russischer Seite
Es war bereits am Anfang klar,
dass es sich bei diesem Konflikt um einen Zermürbungskrieg handelt.
Es war etwas, das
von vielen Experten lange Zeit nicht akzeptiert wurde,
aber es ist tatsächlich der Fall. Wir
können dies sehen, wenn  Wir schauen uns dieses Bild an.
Dieses Bild zeigt ein Gelände in der Nähe
von Parkmut. Ein Gelände, das
mit Granatenkratern gefüllt und mit
Leichen, in diesem Fall von Wagner-Truppen, übersät ist.
Wir können hier sehen, dass wir
einen Krieg führen, mit dem wir nicht gerechnet haben
Tatsächlich wird es in naher Zukunft
einen Krieg geben, der an die
Situation im Ersten Weltkrieg erinnert, und wie
Sie hier sehen können, besteht das Problem darin, dass es an
den russischen Standorten immer noch
an Infanterie mangelt, was es
für sie schwierig macht  um die
ukrainischen Stellungen anzugreifen, und auf der anderen
Seite haben die Ukrainer das
Dilemma, dass sie das Gelände halten müssen,
weil sie wollen,
dass die Russen diese
bestimmten und strategischen Geländeteile besetzen,
was bedeutet, dass wir immer noch einen Krieg haben, der das
auch tun wird  In den nächsten Wochen und Monaten wird die
Artillerie bekämpft.
Die Frage ist nun, wer den längeren
Wind hat. Wir wissen also, dass die ukrainische
Seite vor allem von
den Vereinigten Staaten stark versorgt wird und dass die
europäischen Nationen
auf der anderen Seite bereits Schwierigkeiten haben, mehr Ausrüstung einzuführen  Auf der anderen
Seite wissen wir, dass die russische Seite
bereits mit der Produktion
insbesondere militärischer Ausrüstung begonnen hat und dass
sie immer mehr
moderne Anlagen wie den T90-Panzer einbringt, den wir
in den letzten Wochen bereits auch an der Front gesehen haben,
so die Botschaft  Ich muss für Sie sagen,
dass es noch nicht vorbei ist und dass wir
in naher Zukunft mit weiteren Überraschungen rechnen können.
Wir müssen auch ein wenig auf alle
anderen Nationen achten, die in diesem Konflikt eine Rolle spielen,
nicht nur hinter der Ukraine
wie den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika  Natürlich sind es die
europäischen Nationen oder einige andere
wichtige Akteure, aber auch wenn es
um Russland und Staaten wie China,
Iran oder sogar Indien geht,
ist der Konflikt in einfachen Worten so, als ob beim Boxen
zwei Seiten gegeneinander kämpfen, die
ukrainische Seite und die russische Seite
mehrere Runden lang  Die
meisten dieser Runden wurden bereits von der
Ukraine gewonnen, aber es ist noch offen, wie sich
die nächsten Runden entwickeln werden. Wird es
in naher Zukunft einen Knockout geben oder wird
es andere Überraschungen geben? Werden die
Russen auch in den nächsten Runden bestehen?
Das sind die Fragen  Wir müssen
in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten antworten.
Damit ist mein Briefing für
heute abgeschlossen. Ich möchte mich ganz
herzlich für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit bedanken und am Ende
und natürlich zu Beginn dieses
Jahres möchte ich sagen: Lasst uns hoffen  für
eine schnelle Lösung dieses Konflikts